hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so you guys have asked a
lot and finally I'm delivering today we
are going to do a what I eat in a day
now
honestly this more appropriately would
be called what I randomly ate that day
because there are really are no rules or
consistencies in my diet other than the
fact that like I try to eat a variety of
vegetables in my day and usually I
succeed at that but sometimes I don't
and maybe I'm like traveling a lot or
I'm like working outside the home all
day and that is honestly okay
ultimately my diet is not perfect it's
not clean I just kind of try to eat a
variety of whole foods but I also
believe in convenience as long as I feel
good that's really all that matters to
me but the most important thing I want
to say before we get into this footage
is that this is not intended to be a
diet how to this is not even a recipe
how to this is for entertainment
purposes only not even information
purposes because there is nothing
prescriptive about this diet
honestly this is more kind of like just
like a glimpse into my life as a busy
mom and it's not meant to be a
suggestion of how to eat or even really
a representation of what my daily diet
looks like so without adieu let's take a
look good morning everyone I just woke
up I'm talking really quietly because my
baby's sleeping my dog sleeping my
husband's sleeping and I went to wake
them up but I'm gonna have a little bit
of water and I'm gonna go and do my
workout so if that they started its
doing
okay so we just got back for my workout
and I feel great
I've just refilled my water here I
probably drink like least four of these
a day and the big water drinker but I'm
really obsessed with sparkling water so
I use my SodaStream for that and this is
known that but I just love my SodaStream
I can hear babyyyyy squawking so I'm
going to start to put together some a
really quick little breakfast for him
and I'd have together and of course
they've also still have breast milk for
him and I pumped for him for like the
past year so I've still got quite a good
stash so he has a little bit of breast
milk in the morning as well so let's get
to it because I can hear he wants me to
come get him peanut butter
I see oh that's no I'm just gonna do
this properly okay so baby e is playing
with himself right now and I just really
quickly whipped this up I didn't have
time to do anything like really
extravagant but this is gonna do for his
first kind of like little breakfast and
my little quick breakfast snack after my
workout so about some whole-wheat toast
with some banana and ham parts because
I'm obsessed with hemorrhoids and for
baby eve got some ricotta little berries
some peanut butter toast some hemp
hearts on that so so yummy so I'm just
having a little quick breakfast snack
here with baby e I always try to have my
meals with baby E because it's really
good for modeling eating behavior and
table manners and just starting that
kind of family meal tradition it also
helps when
you know if they're unsure about a
certain food that they see somebody else
that they really trust like mom or dad
or a caregiver eating it they're more
likely to try so if you guys are
struggling with picky eating at home of
course make sure that you're
consistently showing your kids that you
enjoy those kinds of foods that you're
wanting them to eat it really does make
a big difference so that's why of course
I'm kind of having the same foods that
he is today so we're having some peanut
butter toast
lots of hemp art so you can see right
here awesome great as a little
post-workout snack no eating of my mouth
open very rude are you having fun but of
course at a privacy a lot of you guys
probably know I don't show images of
baby II so I just want to kind of keep
his identity to his himself and one day
maybe he'll be a little YouTube
celebrity he's wanting to figure it was
what's going on right now but of course
I wanted to make that decision for
himself so we're gonna enjoy our
breakfast and I will catch you in B do
your food you don't have to have
breakfast right this is what we do
up and it's probably not how papi wants
to eat her double and thank you baby
that's so nice
so as you can hear oh my god this is the
soundtrack of my life died honestly guys
I love love love motherhood but there's
just too much wheels on the bus in my
life
he loves it that's all that matters but
I'm just gonna play here with baby II
until my nanny gets here and my system
gets here I've got a full day of recipe
testing I'm gonna make a little more
breakfast for baby II and I and yeah
enjoy this beautiful calmer day okay
I've been saved by the nannies and
another quick shower
because I've got a really crazy day and
I guess I need to get started eh now my
favorite time of day it's Coffee time
I'm in milk latte action here also I'm
gonna take my probiotic which I take
pretty much every day whenever I
remember of course and that of course is
just really important for keeping my gut
nice and happy that first sip is pretty
much my favorite part of the day let's
get to it
okay so I'm kind of struggling with this
setup here but I'm gonna do my best so
that you can see what I'm doing but I'm
gonna make a really quick little
frittata it's a great way to use up any
leftovers that you have in the fridge
and it's baby II lotsa it's a great way
to get the iron and of course from the
eggs so I've just kind of cleared out my
fridge with any little vegetables and
cheese and things like that that I've
got and I'm gonna have it as a little
mid-morning second breakfast snack kind
of thing and also the same for baby
we didn't you got ton this morning so
I'm gonna assume he's gonna be a little
hungry before he's nap so let's get to
it so I'm using my hubby's eggs from the
farm which are these grass-fed and
free-range eggs and as far as I'm
concerned they're pretty happy hens
though I appreciate that a lot of my
vegans probably wouldn't agree with that
this is the kind of breakfast that I
would like make and then any leftovers
had put in the fridge and I would reply
throughout the week for baby II okay so
before I have anything else in there I
just want to show you how amazing these
look like they are bright orange they
are packed with nutrition so very
excited
on the list and then just based on what
I've got in the fridge I had some cherry
tomatoes that I've just packed I also
thought so like I steam like a ton of
broccoli for baby II so I figure I was
like throw some of this in like the
smaller pieces I've got so much of it I
have a feeling he's gonna get sick of
broccoli this week so it's a great way
to switch it up so it's not just plain
old mmm steamed broccoli that sounds
good though they have salt not too much
salt because baby's happiness so I don't
want to eat
subscribe just went to do that here it's
gonna be a thinner almost like a little
omelette style frittata but I just don't
want this to be so
puffy and thick that baby has a hard
time getting through it so this is gonna
be a perfect size for us we're just kind
of freestyling and there is no rhyme or
reason
alright and then of course we're gonna
add some cheese so I always have Jesus
it's like a really good kind of natural
buffalo mozzarella which is super melty
and delicious so I keep a little bit
shredded just for him for snacking as
well so this is going into a 350 degree
oven or 15 minutes or so until it's nice
and cooked
[Music]
so we've got some little frittata for
babies some Kiwi some avocado I'm gonna
have the same thing just a slightly
larger portion look at how yellow good
and I've got lots of leftover frittata
that I'm gonna pop in the fridge and
have for breakfast or a snack later or
for baby II or snack or lunch as well so
we just made these like awesome kind of
snow bass granola bars that are baby and
toddler friendly and of course like all
the little bits that have fallen if I
cut them this is going to be one snack
today basically mom food mom food are
the scraps the little bits of pieces
that babies don't eat that dogs don't
eat but of course you don't want through
so we don't want to waste food and this
is actually really delicious so it's
just got oats and oat iron-fortified
baby cereal tempered some prunes of
constipation because nobody wants to
constipated baby
lots of natural peanut butter and I
think that's pretty much it it's really
tasty though and I put some freeze-dried
fruit on topically to add some natural
sweetness
and for my moms and dads the recipe for
those amazing baby and toddler friendly
granola bars are in the comments below
and you're probably gonna enjoy them as
well hi okay so we're gonna make a
really quick little lunch
I've been cooking doing some recipe
testing today so I've got some veggies
but of course I want to give me and baby
me a little bit of protein to go with
not close to this fish here I'm going to
[Music]
[Music]
alright so I'm gonna clean up a little
lunch for baby and me so basically as
you're about to see most of the things
that I eat are things that we are like
recipe testing that day for the blog or
channel so that day we had made this
like awesome peach romesco sauce with
like cauliflower steak I'm gonna leave
the recipe down below so you're gonna
want to check that out
but yeah if we're not recipe testing
that day for some reason then maybe I'll
eat like leftovers from the last time we
tested which is probably like just a day
or so before there's always in excess
it's like recipe testing recipes and
food in the fridge and if there's not
then like I'll pick up a salad at the
grocery store or I'll just like compile
random leftovers into a meal but
basically I do not have time to make
myself like a gourmet lunch every single
day with a million other things that we
have going on just not realistic for a
working mom
okay so this is this awesome peach and
roasted red pepper Romanesco sauce that
I made for this recipe that I was
testing today this is the recipe our she
I was testing this has beautiful
cauliflower steaks with this Romanesco
obviously a delicious side but maybe not
enough for me for a main course so I've
just made this little black cod I'm
gonna add some more of the Romanesco on
top just add some extra a little
flavoring sauce same with baby ease I
think he's gonna love the peach kind of
flavor and it's not spicy so it's really
really yummy a little mommy and me lunch
baby we've got the watermelon some fresh
buffalo mozzarella I just took them
little bits from the cauliflower steaks
that kind of fall off and I've seen them
for him so it's really easy to eat and
then we've got some black cod with the
Romanesco and I'm gonna have a
cauliflower steak with the Black Card as
you guys know I am not vegan but I do
try to choose sustainable fish as my
kind of animal food of choice as often
as I can
and this black cod is one of our
favorites in the house this stuff is so
good I could like eat that alone and I
haven't already put it onto my blog yet
I definitely will be soon so it'll be a
link in the description below for this
recipe so that you guys can have it
before the summer is over like yummy
okay so I got to do it gates the house
today for my clinic because I have a
podiatry appointment today
because apparently I've got like Grandma
feet and I need you orthotics but of
course that's a great excuse I needed a
quick little fix it decaf on and Mel
watt a just because I try to stick to
that one coffee day I've really been
trying to cut back to a fertility state
but also because it's the afternoon now
and I know that if I have too much
coffee in the afternoon I am NOT going
to sleep well and I'm a terrible sleeper
to begin them so D captive just wait and
see the doctor
fascinating reading material that was so
strange we just basically made a cast of
my feet but yeah here's how to grab a
seat okay any time for a little
afternoon delight and they say so I'm
gonna put together at my own little
trail mix here with all the randomness
that I have in the covers because if you
saw my pantry you'd be like holy [ __ ]
this girl has way too many snacks so I'm
gonna start with these little chewy
chickpeas they're super awesome
yes you can make your own and I do but
sometimes these brands like slimy stuff
so I'm gonna eat them I've also got some
pistachios that we have spent hours
shelling it's honestly it's kind of
therapeutic to shell pistachios so we we
kind of enjoy it so it's just like a
small handful of that and then I've
bought a small handful of these like
little coconut chips which are super
super tasty a little bit of that I'm
obsessed with these I can't eat them all
day so yeah it looks awesome that's my
little side for this afternoon
so here is my little snack mix excited
to dig in we've got lots of crunchy
things and I like all the crunchy things
but of course all of these things are
choking hazards so not for baby eat
instead these are all of his favorite
foods literally Tomatoes favorite food
grapes favorite food these are these no
added sugar banana peanut butter muffins
that I make for him that are super super
nutrient dense lots of hemp parts as
well which is why I am you know I have
obsessed with and he is obsessed with
these as well these peanut butter banana
mini muffins are amazing they've got no
sugar added so they are definitely one
of my favorites to give baby eat so you
can check out the recipe below
so I'm just gonna quickly get a little
bit of packing down I can hear baby
screaming trying to sleep but not
sleeping of course but we wouldn't cause
tomorrow so I need to get everything
ready so you can get out the door first
thing in the morning so just gonna get
all my bathing suits together I don't
know how like I have no space in my bags
because being needy takes up an entire
bag for all of these stuff
typical typical man but we're gonna try
to try to cram it all in so it is five
o'clock and I mean I'm officially off
the hobbies kitchen work o'clock and on
to my mom o'clock and really honestly
mom clock never stops never starts never
it's just never-ending
and I love it but you've got to have a
lot of energy because my kid is in that
stage what he just does not walk and he
escapes his nap this is good afternoon
so it's gonna be a really great great
witching hour here wish me luck
[Music]
okay so we be basically cooking all day
the last thing I want to do is have to
cook a whole other meal for dinner so
I'm basically just gonna pull together
odds and ends from the fridge and also
we made a big casserole well be a recipe
testing today so I definitely want to
dig into that all right this is awkward
this is her to do okay yeah still looks
pretty good
still looks awesome so this is another
recipe that is now up on the blog so
I'll leave a link below and it could be
made vegan or vegetarian depending on
what kind of cheese that you use but
it's really great it's got like bean
puree in there and tons of veggies and
some whole grain noodles it is really
super tasty and like I said like why
cook from scratch when I have like a
massive casserole in the fridge so we
ate that for dinner and I probably ate
that for like two other days afterwards
just to just to get through obviously
when I shot it for Instagram this
morning it looked better but I think so
looks pretty good and fresh so here's my
portion not sure if I'm gonna eat all of
it but I also served it with some
steamed green beans that I was making
for baby II and I taught mine off with
just a little bit of olive oil and lemon
and then baby II got some steamed
carrots some of the pasta some green
beans and those no-bake granola bars
so one thing that I want to point out is
that yes I served my son to search at
the same time as the rest of the meal
and I do this of course to remove the
novelty factor around dessert and sweet
foods so basically I practice what we
call the division of responsibilities in
feeding so what this means is that me as
a parent I decide what when and where
Neels happens and my son decides if and
how much he's going to eat that is all
on him am i serving dessert with the
main course he learns how to properly
regulate his appetites that he's not
eating to satiety with his main course
and then eating past satiety with his
dessert and I also don't want him to
learn that like the vegetables and the
protein are the gross foods that he has
to drag himself through in order to be
rewarded with some kind of dessert so I
know you guys are thinking this [ __ ] is
crazy
but the reality is that my son will
often eat his broccoli first sometimes
he will eat his dessert first
and sometimes he will alternate Viper
bite he is just listening to his body
and that is amazing ultimately I am just
trying to teach him that dessert is just
another food and not willing to be
obsessed over or hoarded all right so
favorite time of day
babies bath time story and milk so last
little sip of the day okay last little
treat of the night is this strawberry
rhubarb sorbet or sort that toe coupon
me fancy and I've just topped it off
with a little bit almonds for some
crunch and of course the mixture you
know really good fats and some protein
and fiber
so yeah this is my favorite time I day
so good rhubarb anything is the best
really cold though so I'm gonna a little
brain freeze moment but I don't look
worried okay folks I'm gonna start
getting ready for bed I have a very
strict no screen time rule about two
hours ideally before bed that usually
ends up being just like an hour before
bed but still I'm cutting myself off
here folks so I'm gonna wash my face
brush my teeth and take my segments and
then start to read a book so I usually
like to read in bed of course should do
it out of it but I usually read in bed
just to let myself kind of get drowsy as
opposed to watching something on my
phone or an iPad or a television it's a
lot better for your kind of sleep
regulation so I'm gonna start the
routine okay so this is what I'm taking
right now I've got my omega threes I've
got vitamin E for fertility purposes I'm
taking a prenatal multivitamin I'm not
pregnant but anybody that is a woman of
childbearing age should of course take a
prenatal just for safety and then also
some NAC
for fertility purposes so guys there you
have it of course I want to reiterate
that this is not meant to be a diet
how-to it's not prescriptive
it would be really weird for someone try
to like kind of mimic what I'm doing
here because ultimately I was just
letting my body be my guide and of
course like I'm conscious about what I
eat I'm conscious enough to take
supplements because I I know that they
may help my fertility journey I'm
conscious to make more sustainable fish
choices when I go to the grocery store
but there's a difference between being
conscious and being obsessive and you
know who I was like ten years ago that
when I ate today it would be very very
different than what I'm showing you
today and if I took another what I eat
in a day like tomorrow or a week from
now it would also look very different
because again there really are no strict
rules
so I think what I want you guys to take
away from this is that I'm all about
transparency I'm also about you know
everybody kind of trying to find what
works for them and their body and this
is just kind of like what worked for me
that day and that's not necessarily a
consistent thing and some days I listen
really intently to what my body tells me
and sometimes like I don't and that's
okay I don't punish myself for that but
but that's really has been a long
journey for me to get to this point and
my hope for you is that you can also
find your own way in terms of what works
for you and your body so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you have questions if you'd
like to see more or what I ended days if
you'd like to see me review other
youtubers what I in the days of course I
have a whole playlist right here so
check that out don't forget to subscribe
to the channel send this to your friends
and I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]